[Music]
hey babe
[Music]
hey babe
hey babe
welcome to another episode of hey babe
how are you my friend i'm doing good you
look good you got a nice sweater on yeah
yeah i got this 70 off okay let me tell
you this story this is from this company
called g-star raw i know g-star i'm not
trying to do any plugs here okay no more
with the goddamn plugs but right my
point is is that uh i don't particularly
shop there i think they make some things
i really like they have some good codes
good quality right that's not
necessarily my style
inadvertently
someone i work with a colleague of mine
that we exchange gifts okay they they
have given me a g-star raw gift
certificate for christmas of the amount
of five hundred dollars
look at me recently
for the last five christmases
okay now you have twenty five hundred
dollars worth of g-star raw credit no
not credit i used it yeah i owned 2500
materials in this home right okay now
outside of those gift certificates i
spent zero dollars at g-star raw right
right right every year i go all right i
don't know who got in their ear and told
them that i was the
guy for g-star raw but the second year i
was like peculiar the third year i was
like is this the joke the fourth year i
was like interesting yeah because it's
really not displaying effort unless this
person thinks this is really what i want
yeah then it's hats off yeah thank you
for being solid knowing what i want
fifth year in a row now here's another
thing g-star raw does that i don't
really like on the gift certificate it
says in one year this has no value and
they say you can only use it at this
g-star raw location that's ridiculous
that was year one i went into the g-star
roll location i said what is this and
the guy goes yeah that's how we do it
here and i'm like i don't understand
like the customer from the customer
point of view i got this as a gift
you're telling me i got to use it in 365
days then it goes from 500 american
dollars to zero right and i can only use
it in this store not online and not in
the other nine locations
they go yeah
i go okay yeah it doesn't make any sense
to the store
it's like he had given it to me december
before that so i was in there december
of the next year so i was days away from
the year one from the first 500 dollars
expiring right so i walked in and i
couldn't find 500 worth of stuff that i
wanted so i said to the guy well i don't
understand so
if i don't just buy something right now
just to buy it
then you're gonna take this all away
from me and he goes yeah and i go okay
so then i have to buy stuff i don't want
right now and just return it and then
you give me store credit which is good
for how long and he says to me we don't
take returns
and i said what do you mean what i'm not
kidding he goes we do exchanges not
returns so if you buy something now for
the sake of it i can give you a
different size i can't give you the
product back and i said that can't be
right it even sounds illegal and i swear
to you this is what this kid said to me
he goes
i go how do you get away with something
like that i really was but i wasn't
being mean he goes uh
where'd she star raw
and
our theory is
you won't return it you don't need to
we're that
good that's a horrible theory he's a
[ __ ] answer so i bought stuff that i
didn't really necessarily want um and
then
fyi it was december of the following
year so that week he i got a card after
i just exhausted the 500 oh that week
the next 500 and this pattern because i
always wait a full year because i i
don't go in there yeah nothing else the
stuff that i have gotten has been good
and stuff like i get it like every once
a while i'll find something it's a great
sweater that doesn't look insane on me
but like
every year it happens so i go in
december and i spend the 500 and then
the week that week it gives me the new
500.
and he has no idea that you have no
affiliation or even care about g-star
raw in the slides no and i love the guy
and he gives he's a great gift giver he
gives me other gifts
and he gives me personal gifts he gives
me like things and he like he gives me a
book and he'll write in the book like
why he got it like i love the man and
and and and he's a great man but it is
funny that two thousand five hundred
dollars of g-star raw i have gone in
there with gift certificates over the
last five years i'm not gonna say his
name but i think i know who the man is
really i if i had to guess i just can
you hey baby so uh
yeah so so but so my point was this is a
g star so get this
here we are in december
i got last year's 500. so i go in and i
go into the city a trip just for this i
got anxiety hanging over my head you
gotta understand when i get hit with the
500 a week after i spent the 500 which
has been the pattern for five years in a
row i then get a a burden is lifted when
i walk out of there and i'm like oh i
got myself a parka right i got myself a
hoodie right and you know whatever and
then it's like all right now you're on
the clock again you gotta spend this 500
at that location at that location
and so then i go in and i go to location
this
like no joke like
not even a month ago and i and it
shuddered and i go oh my god it's closed
and so i walk across the street into a
scotch and soda right not a nice line
yeah great line and uh they were closed
and i saw a guy named knock and i go
you're supposed to be open and he goes
the machines are down and i said well
all right but so now what he goes well
will you pay with a credit card i go
sure so he let me in and i said hey
fella do you know what's going on across
the street because i told him the whole
thing i told you he really was he was a
nice guy he listened and he goes uh oh
they're closed permanently and i go oh i
must i'll have to go to the location he
goes no no they're closed permanently
too and i go what he goes yeah they
closed all their locations
g-star raw has folded this is what he
told me the g-star raw yeah he says at
least in the new york area every
location new york city is closed he goes
you may be able to go online i came home
i drafted us a firm letter an email and
an electronic communication and i wrote
to g-star and i was like i told him
everything and they gave me a code to
use 500 they're still doing online
so i took the 500 cold i went online
this was
70 percent off 7-0 it was listed at 140
dollars and and i bought it for 42
dollars and wow it's a good second time
i wore it it's a and i'll tell you what
it's a hell of a fit thanks and shindigo
died so they do say be careful because
the garment if you go on a light fabric
so i'm also
they're giving me anxiety in different
ways now and g-star raw is one of those
things where it just fits it's good i
had an aunt who very similar to your
friend
didn't know didn't understand whatever
you know when i was you know maybe 15
years old for about three christmases in
a row no gift cards or nothing bought me
opened up gift on christmas a fubu
sweatshirt
my aunt janet did that three years in a
row it was bought a fubu sweatshirt a
little white kid with blonde hair got
his hair cut at supercomputer score us
by us four hours by his fubu sweatshirt
that she picked out does fubu have
retail themselves brick and mortar
because i always say fubu in like
marshalls yeah i don't know and the guy
damon john john shout out damon john
jonathan johnson one of my favorite
trucks who yeah was one of the favorite
sharks god bless fubu too i'm saying
when i see it it's usually in a
marshalls but i think that's where you
get like the next season like the maybe
the irregularities you ever buy
something a regular
steep discounts on a regular and you'll
find them uh they used to be in the
outlet stores but now you go to like a
marshalls or a tj maxx and you finally
say i'll tell you a real nice treat
something is has a steep discount okay
and because it's marked on the tag
irregularly they're transparent about
that you say it says a compare ad i love
to go into marshalls and tj maxx and i
love to compare at the receipt it says
like you like this uh candle motive it's
not uh it's uh it's eight dollars
compare at 29.99 and then they let you
know right there the savings you're
getting right there right there right
there so what i do is i will go into um
to like a marshalls and you find
something irregular but you search the
garment up and down and you can't even
spot the irregular right and then you
bought it in a regular and at a regular
price right uh that's that's a fun
little victory
see i'm one of those guys where i if i
could if i could every single outfit of
mine i'd wear a batting practice
baseball jersey because it hides my
because i have an irregular body but you
do have a good jersey body good jersey
body when i take off my shirt it's a
it's just a letdown multiple women in my
life have either i've taken off my shirt
you know right before i have sex and
they've turned the lights off as soon as
they took on my shirt or if they've
asked me to put my shirt back on
i swear to god oh my god no
how do you deal with that there's a girl
on top of me for me i just wear a snow
suit yeah and i just i don't even no
there was a girl on top of me once and i
was go like she was until we were having
in the midst of it and i was going to
take my shirt off and she put her hand
on my chest and said don't
i swear to god
i swear oh my god
she goes down
[Laughter]
[ __ ] what a terrible person for honest
honest i don't know that should give you
a dose like what how do you feel about
her i mean well she stopped i'm
literally lightheaded right now i'm
spinning around my head
we we had sex that one and only time as
you would imagine don't she goes don't
i was going to take my shirt off in the
heat of passion
okay let's let's let's talk about this
and i forgot what we got but do you
think that maybe she was just like i
can't even wait like don't even bother
no no we were actively having sex and i
went to take it off because it was
sweltering in my room and she she
whispered don't and put her hands on my
chest uh just you have a wonderful build
no but i don't want crazy talk when i
take my shirt off i just i flabby tit
it's just weird like you don't and he at
the time you're a good clothes
box
come on never went to that boxing ring
in in kentucky that was within
somebody's house yeah well you looked up
the guy who was like the gus a motto or
domado whatever yeah yeah you looked up
the guy who was like he was like
i i don't even i don't know his name and
i forgot he was an older man who ran a
boxing a full boxing gym out of his
residential home yeah that was also like
a 200 year old house
he was
it was something out of a movie i have i
have video we have video on photos i
have a video of you shout out i like
doing remember he he got you on the
bench yeah here's what i did i stayed
because i was like all right let's drive
there together and maybe you go in i'll
go because i'm not going to box you know
like and then we got up there and it was
like
the most unique
unbelievable he he has adopted adopted
children he takes care of cincinnati but
this was in kentucky i think it was in
kentucky we went into kentucky an old
school kentucky
boxing gym a house uh a ring in the
house that was there for 30 plus and i
stayed there for like like 80 minutes
just videoing you boxing it was yeah
yeah and then sal walks in and then sal
walks in and then i heard one of the
guys on the pads he got one guy who says
to the other guys goes he goes yo i've
seen that [ __ ] before and the
guy in pad goes yeah he was on best week
ever
yeah that's what he said
yeah your boxes she said don't she said
don't yeah she said don't so but you
know listen it's it's you know and i've
said this on many podcasts i also had a
casting director uh you know nice guy
who was actually casting my cbs pilot he
said to me he said do you know
what your problem is
and i said no not that i asked for it
but i guess what is it he goes you have
leading man face best friend body
so you're not castable either be one or
the other either be the leading man and
get ripped or get fat and be the best
friend and you're hovering in no man's
land i'm hovering over and saying he
said but you're only out is to create
old thinking you create
why can't you be
the guy that you are i know that's gonna
be i don't agree with that well you know
what is this man say his name
mark hirschfeld while you son mark zu
push in here mark if you're listening
and we know you are you nick lachey and
a few hundred priests are listening all
the time yeah lulu's listening saratoga
we know we know who our listeners are no
actually mark carson's a great guy it's
not mark hershfield that's another guy i
just blanked on who it was so i said
actually one of the nicest men in
casting it was not mark hirschfeld i
forgot the counseling right and said
that markers a great guy but for the
point of the story let's pick it up i'm
just playing along too now if herschel
didn't do it i'm not going to give him
the business mark hershfeld was one of
the original casting directors of
seinfeld and was telling me seinfeld
casting stories day one like with larry
david and jerry seinfeld while we were
doing my pilot wow like unbelievable wow
someone came to me a couple of days ago
who worked for comedy central and told
me that your animated pilot that they
that was over there was
they thought and it was widely thought
at comedy central was one of the
funniest things like they had ever seen
and then it got it's just the thing is
that the network changed hands and the
new guy chris mccarthy just said
they just can't that's what they told me
and the show was gone it's this is pr i
would say that's happened to me
four times yeah where the the
do you ever tell you about my cbs pilot
i know yeah i know but this is a true
story yeah the cbs that i had with
chad's commentary playing my father it
was a story about my life in cbs we
filmed the pilot the day that they were
the day not the day before the day that
you
picked cb les moonves at the time and
his executives there's maybe nine pilots
that's how it works at these major
networks and they're gonna pick three or
four les moonves you know
there's less movies and then his the man
right on them was a man named glenn
geller who was a champion of our show he
just liked our show he was at the pilot
taping he liked our show oh he's weird
it came down they had picked three shows
they needed one more it had come down to
the one show who was it going to be
glenn geller who was a champion who had
less moon vision he was directly under
command les moonves personal hire had a
heart attack the morning that they were
picking the shows
and was in surgery and no representation
we had no representation
and they picked another show
that's the way that's the way the cookie
crumbles and
and and and this man today has he ever
called you an apologized no nothing
and he survived glenn glenn geller great
guy glenn we know he's worth listening
you know we know you're listening you're
the head of cbs development les moonves
is glenn and glenn are listening right
now glenn pick a phone maybe you know
what i mean like we you know he no one
could have anticipated your heart attack
but also like entered the dust settled
he should be a major network star right
now because because you have been
laying on margarine thick for a couple
of decades this man is not gonna realize
his full potential because you like to
fill every nook and cranny yeah with i
would like to ask you glenn right now
how selfish
did you want to be
you didn't think about me at all you
just thought about yourself talking
about at the moment we're not talking
about the moment we're being reasonable
but after you were released make a
hospital and you see that you didn't get
slated there's no like look i've made a
lot of i made a lot of unhealthy choices
at brunch
for a long time a long time and i didn't
know it would come to that at that
moment it was going to affect chris's
show
right now i have a pilot at true tv that
i've been told
all all signs point that it's gonna get
picked up but i said i'm chrissy pilots
i've had nine pilots wow not one of them
has went nine of them so don't think
well there's only something that can
happen before we got jokers we had uh i
think four or five failed pilots right
so i mean and then who do
and i you know you just never know i
mean i didn't i didn't know that anyone
would take to this show like this and
and be on this on the story didn't you
like come you forgot you had the pitch
meeting or something isn't that like a
crazy story we had the pitch meeting
before we had an idea for a show
and you were like coming with ideas on
the ferry or something yeah we had it
well no what we do i'll tell you what we
did actually we had it we had scheduled
a round of pitch meetings sometimes they
call them generals yeah but you want to
go in there with something right just
because you want the washington generals
who play the harlem globetrotters
absolutely not no no no no i didn't get
a bucket i didn't get a bucket of
sequins in my face
nobody hit a half court shot no not at
all but um no so we had these and we're
like we don't just want to go in there
and not have anything so we said let's
go to lunch and think of a show
and uh oh think of anything i think of
any shows we and we went to royal crown
bakery
on staten island said
some of the best muffins i've ever had
in my life shout out to carmen
outside
and we had a light lunch right and uh we
got i thought of the idea for the show
at the lunch you thought of it actually
we did yeah all for you yeah and then um
we went with our cell phones that week
that i mean two days later we went the
four of us only with our cell phones and
we shot like five bits in like in and
around times square cut the cell phone
footage together brought that and we
first went to mtv
and they came back immediately i'm sorry
uh yeah they came back immediately
offering to buy it but they wanted to
make it a game show that was on five
days a week with a host and the people
that played against each other were just
contestants and we said now we kind of
want to be the recurring characters that
people get to know and then they would
root for us or not and we want them to
get to know us so it's not just a game
show we wanted more than that and then
we went uh true a couple of days later
and uh they offered us
to pick up the show in the in the room
like no pilot like we're going to give
you eight episodes uh no it's a pilot
right but they offered it in the room
right and um we got and they're going
with them and then we shot the pilot and
they liked it and uh uh they ordered
eight off the pilot and then when we
were filming the fourth episode they
said another eight and they pushed it to
sixteen and then from then
we would have never ever i mean
we had a hundred ideas just like this
you know it's like i don't know yeah
clicks with people yeah just
a throw away like let's try it it was
wow do you have that cell phone footage
did you ever post that like the other do
you have it yeah it's not like the first
tour we ever did like eight nine years
ago whatever we showed it yeah we kind
of did like a little origin like this is
this is what we shot this is what became
the show that's insane and that was what
10 years ago it was uh
the cell phone footage
at that point it was probably
early 2010. wow yeah that's crazy dude
it's wild it's wild how [ __ ] like that
just happens like in life and tv where
it's like you have no idea that like
what you're doing is gonna lead to like
a major thing like even even life stuff
like when i met
my kid's mom who would you know my girl
yeah i
i
wasn't even gonna go to the bar that
like i wasn't even my friend pat was
like just come to bars like i don't want
to do it i don't there's no part of me
that wants to go to the bar he was like
dude just come it's like literally
what's one drink is not going to change
your life that's what he said you know
wow yeah i'll never forget that's why he
varies he said onedrick's not going to
change your life wow so then i go meet
her
she's pregnant within a month and i was
like one drink it was a long island iced
tea unfortunately there's a lot of
outfits it changed my life so i always
think about that how it's like you don't
even know like you can wake up one day
and like i know it's not like tragic or
deep but it's like you can wake up one
day like your life is gonna change in
that day and you have no idea
dude i mean prior to that you know i
have a degree in finance i worked like i
was st john staten island that's right
which by the way i drove past st john
staten island the other day what a
gorgeous what neighborhood is that yeah
that's
that
hill i mean
some of those some of the houses that
look there was like a gated community it
looked like malibu yeah yeah what
community is that wild up there yeah
it's unlike grimes i don't know three
four million
yeah it was pretty it's pretty nice over
there yeah but uh yeah that's what i i
mean i had that and then i and then i
worked like
at prudential
right for like five years and i was
doing like not doing comedy at all i was
doing comedy but i was like doing like
sketch improv and i actually was doing
like writing workshops and i did like
some open mics
and uh
and uh you know i was just doing it on
the side
and then i left there and became a
bartender because i was like i don't
want to be here this is not what i'm
going to do so i left and i was like
bartending flexible schedule i could do
more comedy and while i'm doing this
i'll learn the bar business right and
save money and then if
nothing happens maybe i'll i'll i'll buy
a bar and that's what i end up doing
yeah because you had that bar what was
it called cargo lounge the cargo cafe
cabinet then i but i would work there
and imagine then i went to another place
but like my point was that like
at one for like eight years working
there i worked off the books with no
health insurance no medical insurance
and i i was in a um i lived for for 10
years in a uh studio little basement
studio apartment i think i might have
told you this yeah like i didn't know i
think i was gonna be there long so i
never even bought a mattress so i slept
on my couch for like nine and a half
years you slept on your couch for nine
and a half years didn't have a bed yeah
and no health insurance i mean that's
absolutely insane no health insurance
and worked off the books
nine years you didn't get them i was
like 33 years old 34 years old
my first mattress was in 2010
july july 1st 2010 my first mattress
that's just and i and and i took an old
one what kind of couch were you sleeping
on
it was like a leather um it's about this
length no it's longer than this and you
wonder why your feet face different ways
yeah that's true that's true i mean
could you imagine not that's literally i
would imagine that's what isis is doing
to their prisoners
it's making them sleep on the sofa like
at the time i moved out of there i had
slept on that thing nearly one third of
my life
you're a guy that told me too the most
important things you could ever do is
get a comfortable mattress and buy good
sneakers to spend money on because of
the percentage of the days that you
spend on your feet and sleeping and yet
you for nine and a half years
didn't listen your own advice i will say
this if it was a problem if it was
problematic i probably would have had to
seek something else but the couch was
fine it's suffice to find if you ever
brought a lady over what did you explain
to them that you have no mattress yeah i
kind of did you would just say i don't
have well for like i think a lot because
we're not talking about it a big portion
of it i was in a relationship and then
she had an apartment so she never slept
over because there's nothing once what i
would do is okay so this is what
happened right so i thought i'd be out
right away uh and and when i moved in
there as a gesture my dad got these
couches for me shout out to sal's daddy
shout out daddy and uh
and the couches were a three
and then a love c which is a two yes and
then a single yeah so he bought the
whole
raymore flanagan get up right and and uh
and it was a it was a living room it was
like i set it up like a living room but
there was no room for the bed
and um so when you know the girl i dated
you know was already like what if she
ever stayed over like i i pushed the uh
love seat
head on into this couch to make a like a
franken couch like a makeup but this one
was like a good foot shorter than that
one right so i would lay on the long
couch and and then she would lay next to
me on the short couch
so
okay because it sounds batshit crazy to
talk about it it is this is it is sound
this is i'm talking
no joke i moved into the the the studio
apartment in the year 2000 and i moved
down the year 2010. so i'm talking right
now i'm talking 21 years ago right that
i was doing this but like
it's it was fine like there was no i
don't have anything to you know i was in
a relationship long term serious like it
wasn't a thing like the apartment was
okay it was nice and everything but it's
like it was fine it's yeah but i did
that
it's not that way that you did that on a
couch in a studio apartment on staten
island yeah wow as a matter of fact we
did a pilot we talked about failed
pilots my first pilot ever was a pilot
that
fox and spike bit on with the guys where
we it was a single camera sitcom we
played like these exaggerated versions
of ourselves and we shot the pilot
presentation it was like an origin story
and we shot it in that apartment and i
literally gave them a tour and i showed
them that this is where i sleep in the
pilot do you have that footage
somewhere i do yes i do i'd like to see
that footage and the cell phone footage
guess where you can find it patreon.com
no fresh network you can it's where
we're going to post it that's what
that's what i want to say on the patreon
wagon because patreon is going to be a
lot of fun all these extra things that
come out of nowhere are going to go to
the patreon right to the patreon i mean
can you make a note of those i'll find
those patreon.com no pressure network if
you want to see that babe it's just it's
just it's you have a fascinating you're
a fascinating
character to me
in the sense of
nine and a half year because the amount
of time i don't think what people
understand is nearly 10 years to do that
yeah is
i was perfectly happy like my rent was
utilities included here's listen to this
listen to this scam i had going yeah
okay i i lived there through four owners
of that home four owners changed hands
and i stayed in the basement and they
threw through all every other not one of
the owners was like i'm not i'm not so i
befriended each owner yeah because they
have to negotiate the deal with the old
previous orders saying
the tenants say they say i got a guy
downstairs quiet as all get out doesn't
even have a bed pays his dog pays his
bills on pays his bills on time you
don't even know he's there yeah and uh
and and i befriended and what i got was
so the i when i started there my rent
was 650 utilities included in this in
the summer i mean it's ridiculous 650
you can lose included and then when he
left and the next guy came he told him
listen
the guy pays 600
because what was customary is new guy
takes over they usually jack up about 50
bucks a month and i would get back to
where i was and in essence the rent
wouldn't go up well p.s
the next guy didn't raise it
and that happened again
and again so i was there ten years when
i first started day one my rent was 650
utilities included when my and when i
exited it after 10 years my rent was 500
utilities included oh my god i didn't
need to go anywhere i didn't need to go
anywhere 500 i was going right into my
pocket that money wow the savings was
astronomical i was able to buy a bar
from it
that's literally you bought a bar you
didn't have a bed you bought a bar yeah
you bought a bar before you bought a
mattress that's right
i mean what other podcast does that
happen
yeah just i just like it it was fine for
me you know no i don't think i i'm not
you it's a it's a beautiful thing how
content you are well i don't get it like
i don't know i don't understand i have
my car is like well over a decade old
right beautiful car i don't care i got a
car i i i bought it i thought it was a
little too expensive to buy but i wanted
to pay off everything and not have any
payments and for like over six years now
i've had no payments and i drive around
this car and what i was going through uh
security someplace and they were like oh
sal and i'm like oh hey dude man the guy
i guess you know people talk and they
don't think they're just like honest
with you and he's like oh wow i
wouldn't imagine to be driving this
i was like well what'd you think he goes
ah some new really like expensive type
of car or whatever and i was like yeah
you know yeah i don't need that or
whatever and he's like yeah he goes
i don't know why i said that
i remember getting i don't know why i
just said that i was like it is what it
is i remember i remember
you and i doing a gig last year i'm
forgetting where it was maybe it's with
five and a half hours upstairs i mean i
did just lease a new car but it was the
first but in 10 years it was my 12 years
i remember getting into that car last
year you already had the show and you
already you know had the amazing career
and i remember getting into the car and
asking you is this car going to make it
to our gig
shakes when you get over 65. yeah
yeah but i loved it it was a great ride
i fell asleep i was like i can't believe
this is going to make it but oh my god
that was the time with a really really
really real really bad storm yes
you fell asleep i tried so hard to be
honest
six hours
in in what i would call el nino cubed
yeah it was so bad that my wipers
couldn't keep up
for the six-hour drive yeah you stayed
up for like two hours and you don't i
don't know look i knew once you're in
the pilot position yeah you just do what
you need to do you were my
responsibility at that point yes and
then you know those i would do this for
you i know and i tell you right now i
was driving that night i tell you right
now dude i was white knuckling that
thing because another thing was it was
raining so hard that i kept hydroplaning
everywhere because the tires weren't
like big traction tires no
man while you were sleeping we swerved
around so much that god was with us that
night shout out to all the priests shout
out to all the priests and then i
remember going into your hotel room the
next morning we got the conjoining hotel
rooms and you at that point were were on
a very very very strict keto low carb
diet and you had ordered you had ordered
a full pizza i saw a whole pizza box i
saw a whole pizza box and i said oh sal
you cheated and then i lifted up the
entire pizza was there he had ordered
pizza and ordered all the toppings on
the pizza and only in the ate the
toppings off the pizza which i said this
man has skinned animals alive
i said this man is
hey babe serial killer yeah i couldn't
believe it and then i remember eating
what i finally committed with no
toppings
who's skinning cats i know who's getting
cats now i told you i killed the cat by
accident once no we
here's the thing here's what i'm gonna
here's what's happened to me i have no
short-term memory whatsoever yeah none
you're like drew barrymore i is that
somebody's first date oh okay yeah
i love how
yeah i have i don't have it i don't know
in the
five episodes before this if i've told
this story no me neither i have no clue
none of us
who cares we repeat them
you know
guys what do you want me to do so i
remember the other day we were talking
and you said to me look me and i said
chris
how do i live a happier life i don't
remember that but continue but i said to
you yeah if you don't remember because
you were living a not happy life
days ago i was in a fog so don't blame
you i didn't remember you weren't living
a happy life a few days ago but what did
i say to you when you said how do i live
a happier life where did i tell you to
go told me to go to betterhelp.com and
you told me to put backslash hey babe
right get 10 off my first month what
this is is it's online counseling that's
what you told me right and did you take
me up on the offer i did not but i plan
to right is that bad i mean i just been
busy the last couple days no because i
wanted to tell you that's why i'm
bringing it up to you i took it up on
myself because i said you know what
sal's not going to do it because he's
not invested in getting in happier life
i know i am and i believe in this oh i i
am and i believe in it and and you know
i don't have the time nor the energy uh
to go out to uh to get get counseling
but plus i'm a loud talker but sal but
that's what i'm saying i'm always afraid
someone's gonna hear me from the waiting
room you know what sal and that's why
i'm happy to be doing this and we have
this all on camera is you're not a good
you're not listening to me because i
told you sal as i've been telling you as
we've been friends for years you don't
listen to me i told you that
betterhelp.com
hey babe is online counseling you don't
have to go out you go the therapist
comes on your computer and if you put in
the promo code hey babe at
betterhelphelp.com you get 10 of your
first month because you've been telling
me i have no money 10 that's amazing
that's like no tax and then some yes
yeah yeah i'm low on funds you're low on
funds i mean you know i mean what are
they gonna do i mean you know i mean you
don't get paid for the
stuff
to online now yes
yes
why should this be any different it's
discreet yeah convenient it's affordable
it's probably more affordable than other
online services 100 it's more affordable
than other online services that i may or
may not be on that my father doesn't
know about but he does know about him my
family's very supportive of me being on
betterhelp.com and using the promo code
hey babe for getting 10 off my first
month because everyone wants to save a
little scratch here and there it's true
and it's better help h-e-l-p i want a
happy wife and a happy life and i have a
happy life
and if you've been thinking about it why
not take the leap there's nothing to
lose try it because in these times we
all could use a little mental massage
absolutely we could use a mental massage
or or massage after hours but if we want
to go mental we go mental the
betterhelp.com hey babe so what happens
you almost killed a cat i was driving
down lindhurst avenue in rosebank toward
bayshore bank yes i was in my plymouth
reliant k car which was the old driver's
ed car okay that i had bought for nine
hundred dollars while i was delivering
pizza and i called it old brown and i
had my girlfriend this was like high
school like like just right at high
school and i had my girlfriend in the
car and my sister
who's 10 years younger than me and we
were going to polymer video on bay
street to rent a vhs still there palmer
video long gone now it's a vet imagine a
video store was still there it's
actually a vet which is kind of ironic
to this story because
we were going to the video store which
is now that it wasn't then and as i was
driving down that block at a moderate
pace mind you not speeding right
a cat ran in front of my car and i
slammed on the brakes and i hit the cat
and killed the kids
and i was like oh and
let me tell you something right now i
don't have a strong constitution yeah i
cry at commercials yeah i've never
killed i'm an animal lover yeah i remind
you i don't like cats but like i don't
want to kill a cat no no i don't tell me
the the unthinkable happened i went to
something and i looked in the thing and
i saw it in the street like and i'm
sorry this is graphic it's a fine story
it ends up okay
i pulled over i was in shock and i get
out and i was going toward the cat and
there were people sitting outside on
their front like like porches and lawns
and a couple of people came over and
they were like oh my god you hit the
neighborhood stray
he's blind and i look at the cat and the
cat has no eye in one and a [ __ ] a
completely messed up eye on the other
like the socket has no eye in it oh my
god the other one has like it's just all
jacked yeah and they go it's not your
fault the cat's blind don't don't feel
bad and i go i i don't know what to do i
cannot leave this cat here i go i have
to go to a vet with this cat so they put
um
someone went and got a box a brown box
and a shovel and a blanket
and they lit we lifted the cat we put
the cat in the box wrapped in a blanket
so you you put your hands on this cat oh
my blind i didn't but the na the guy in
that who brought out the blanket the
lady brought the blanket in the box they
put it in the box for me they knew the
cat they used to feed it okay like it's
our neighborhood cat we all feed it it's
dripping and blood this thing it wasn't
bleeding
right but
inside the fur had to be like things
shifting around right yeah you know
and so i
went to another animal hospital like a
couple of miles away okay and i walked
in and i said pimp just googled cats
with no eyes there there they are that's
what that's what the son of a [ __ ]
looked like yeah yeah okay comes up and
i walked into the i walked into the vet
and i said excuse me uh which was which
which is the vet at the time no no this
is another vet but right now the place i
was going to rent a video
is a vet now yeah but i i drove was it
was again prime heart video what was it
palmer palmer video arnold palmer arnold
palmer so uh i go and i walk in and i
say hello
the car in front of me
the car in front of me i was driving
behind it uh hit this cat and kept going
yeah i can't you know being the person i
am i can't have that yeah i was young i
was scared i didn't really know what the
protocol was right i never hit anything
so i just didn't want i didn't know if
he was going to report me yeah i didn't
know if they were going to be like you
owe us 25 000. i don't know what was
going to go on right so he goes and the
doctor like didn't buy it the vet didn't
buy it from the second he's like oh yeah
it happens and i was like yeah and he
goes uh he goes so yeah this we got to
put him down and i was like oh my god
i'm so sorry you're like i'm so sad and
i go wow
and he goes yeah so we incur this cost
and i was like
yeah yeah and he goes so
if you want to put something toward it
it would be appreciated
and i was like yeah i was like man i
wish that car
that was in front of me stopped because
it's so wrong that yeah that he's not
gonna contribute to this right and uh he
was like yeah and he just kind of like
meanwhile there's whiskers coming out of
the front of your car
yeah there's a buck
you got it on the g-star raw sweater
and didn't you just say that you love
animals and you don't want to kill
anything and then live on camera you
killed that thing i don't care i'll kill
a nat i'll kill it now i'll kill the
nets family i'll kill i i'll kill that i
don't know what ecological uh effect
that'll have on the world and by the way
i gotta remember to put the mic up to my
mouth it's okay but i'll kill i'll kill
every single night and then worry about
it later you don't think about it you'll
step on a road you'll kill a roach
that's gonna be dead in a in a in a day
anyway isn't it i don't know what's this
it was spanish
you better get
square one main trait wasn't annoyance
right i would be fine with it i'd be
like fly around do your thing actually
was flying out of your beard
you looked like it came out of your
beard it's very by the way i gotta be
honest with you sal it landed in there
and i slapped your hair this is the look
that i hope you always keep is that
right i was trying to grow my hair out
for three weeks as soon as it touched my
ear
i cut my hair oh
you like this i want to grow my hair
just like you like a long time
to grow at the end my last
well i've gotten two haircuts in nine
months right uh
so you went here like this like that uh
in you know in march march you had you
had a regular haircut i had this hair in
my life before i like the bat i've had
hair and i i will mark it down i'll give
you the i'll give you the picture i had
hair ready it was
three times this length college college
i look like grunge it was like to your
shoulders
what and you put up in a ponytail yes
hit me in the top tip would you put up
in the top ten here yeah good tapped in
hair yeah tth and i i used to shave
underneath though i didn't have this
that's cool
it looks awesome like this
it's my name it's really it's curly and
flowy
yeah you know what it is we have to keep
the same haircut for the show so the
show's on
i can't be on one scene like that and
once like this but then at the
quarantine all bets are wrong i said i'm
gonna go on do not look at the tv how do
you spell nat
gnat wow you knew that there was a g a
lot of people don't know that yeah i
would i was thinking right in the head i
was thinking that
oh yeah n-a-a-n-a-t i don't know what
that is and where that g comes from
ganette yeah good gnu
gary the canoe isn't that gnu something
too there's no good news like good good
news gary
i'm showing my age showing my age i
don't know uh
so anyway he says to me he says yeah i
go yeah i wish that guy would have
stopped and he goes yeah
and then it was silence it was almost
like a larry dave like a curb moment
where they go where they look at each
other like
when he's like dude
look at each other like that he kind of
did that to me and then i reached to my
wallet and i remember it was the year i
first got i'll tell you what year it was
it was 1995 because it was the it was my
second credit card i ever got it was a
discover card okay and my first one was
94. my shout out discover card that came
up online oh there you go there's one on
me on the right with the long hair i
mean how old were you there uh i was uh
let's let's think about this real quick
i was uh post this on the patreon 19
19 years old
very very
chiseled chiseled chin and beautiful
long hair you look like you look like a
lesbian yeah i did look like a lesbian
right you look like a beautiful lesbian
yeah actual beautiful beautiful girl
yeah i actually i mean gorgeous gorgeous
feel much different than a beautiful
lesbian either
wow
yeah that's me and that's me when i was
15. you mer and joe
yeah wow
crazy right that just comes up
that's me in high school i wonder where
they found that i'm sure at one time or
another people i don't know who knows no
idea where q was in that so i reach in i
pull out my discover card by the way
still have it joe remember since 95. in
this picture that that we have up and we
can post this picture joe gotta look he
looks like a black man from the 60s
that's what he looks like a black man in
nineteen twenty feel like
that's what with his hair that he looks
like that he did have very coarse hair
yeah yeah yeah
great
so great yeah so he says he goes how
much i go i got do you take discover he
says yeah because he goes uh how much do
you want me to put on here and i go um
25
yeah i mean that was i mean i was
18 right and uh he he rang it up 25
bucks and then put the cat to sleep and
then gave me a death certificate
with it was a receipt death certificate
for the cat and and he and it's like an
official one and he wrote on this day of
blah blah and then it wrote like it was
in there like cat's name like it was
blank like a mad lib right and he just
wrote stray
wow yeah do you have that stuff i do
oh my god if you don't go to patreon.com
i mean the amount of things you're
missing
are epic i know i haven't i've seen it i
know i would never throw it out i will
find it i don't know when that'll be up
on the paint okay okay
that's freaking interesting man yeah i
yeah i i'm not i just i don't
necessarily
love animals i think i've told stories i
i had a dalmatian cruella did i ever
tell you about cruella no i didn't know
yeah so i had a dalmatian cruella who i
liked but was scared of [ __ ] i grew up
with i grew up but well not really we
had it for about six months because the
main thing was don't let her go into the
basement but how old were you
11. okay and she had bitten like she had
chewed up my last my like a pair of
sneakers that my grandpa just bought so
you can't leave her into the basement i
never knew why my mom was like no she's
never allowed to go in the basement i
said okay so then is there a chocolate
factory i had no idea well worse she she
uh she pissed me off or whatever or i
just didn't like dogs or i was just
being a dumb little kid and i let her go
in the basement and hours went by and
the dog never came up she had gotten
down into the basement eating all the
clorox and died on the basement floor
that's one story the second story i
swear yeah
i mean
i never knew this about you yes not
uncommon you do this to me a lot but i
sat here
going crazy that i hit a blind cat
feeling the guilt for it and you don't
mention that you basically poisoned your
own dog it was your own dog my own talk
clorox clorox it was accidental right
but it happened wow so we've both killed
an animal act yeah i guess
inadvertently then
then my aunt had a uh a pet bunny rabbit
named annabelle had a yeah had had a pet
bunny rabbit named annabelle
and you're like lenny from of mice and
men
yeah
so annabelle so this is just what
happened and my uncle shout out uncle
victor r.i.p uncle victor great guy
right from the motherland of puerto rico
just a fantastic guy
he annabelle dies one morning i'm going
to school he would walk me to school
sometimes i'll never forget
my mother had just given me a sandwich i
have a brown paper bag you know uh with
my lunch i'm walking down the stairs my
uncle says please hold on
annabelle died
takes he doesn't
he doesn't have a bag or anything that i
have the lunch bag dumps my lunch out
puts
out i'm not like puts annabelle the dead
rabbit in a bag in like a brown brown
with half its tail still sticking out
was go the plan was to walk to go to the
supermar or the store on the corner to
get a plastic bag wrap it up and we were
going to bring it to a vet he sees the
garbage truck coming down the block
and throws annabelle the dead rabbit
into the garbage truck right in front of
me i hear the thing the garbage men
don't see it's just more garbage in the
truck they don't know it's a dead rabbit
i hear it coming down and i hear like uh
what i thought was bones crushing
bones crushing onto the back of the
garbage truck and i walked into school
holding a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich in a ziploc bag a bag of
carrots and a little thing of milk and
my
sister seraphine rip sister seraphine
the principal of the school same with
that square win says why is there no
lunch bag i said cause uncle victor put
out
[Laughter]
that was that's when you want to hear
that
i was i was spiraling into depression
yeah
that gaseous baseline just pulled me up
from the ashes yeah right there that
smart sound by the way is one of those
farts isn't that real that's a real
story
it's like like your ass is like
chocolate can we hit it again
yeah so this fart just over here yeah
[ __ ] is charles man i remember it
ricocheting and there was like a breeze
that hit the back of my ball sack
because of the angle it went
it kind of shut up that way
[Laughter]
you hear the reverberation it sounds
like you i'm turning on an old car
it sounds like the beginning to the
theme song for what's happening can you
can you put on the use of it's like
what's happening
and then hear the fart
to that set
[Laughter]
listen to this the mother on this sitcom
was name was mabel king she lived in a
building called the continental towers
which is like an affluent residential
building in manhattan when my dad was
young one of his first jobs ever he was
the doorman she had a crush on him wrote
him a note that he kept that i read when
i was little he used to be on the wall
in his office and said to my lovely
darling sal i love you so much my
sweetie pie i love mabel king wow yup so
mabel king could have been with nelson
hey hey hey shirley two grapes hey hey
hey yes you don't know that you ever
know i've just never seen the show rerun
is that yeah rerun dance okay
yeah no i think shirley i gotta watch
the show oh it's great it's like good
times era you know
maybe even it's actually after good
times i think yeah he i mean he's he has
a he's famous for it the rerun dance
yeah he gets down
right he gets down look
oh my god this guy's awesome
[Laughter]
here's what i want i want you to i want
us to learn that dance choreographed
thousand percent uh i i i on the patreon
patreon.com no pressure that way we're
just like some of these things are not
going to be delivered yeah but like if
we could learn that dance together would
both be rerun for halloween and we just
go in there and do it here's what i want
to issue though a challenge to our
listeners
i want to have annabelle
uh the deceased rabbit
i want to do a comic strip about what
might have happened if she came back to
life
out of the truck i'd love to do that
maybe she ate something like it was like
a superhero story she ate something that
was slightly toxic and it gave her and
then she was reanimated yeah maybe we do
a little comic strip of annabelle the
formerly deceased rabbit right and the
adventures of that of that rabbit did i
ever tell you the story about the the
house party about the recently deceased
rabbit
may be our mascot
annabelle the recently deceased rabbit
is the master yeah
yeah you know what i mean i like it yeah
because it's giving new life right to
her and her story right and about the
recently deceased rapper
yeah so so there's that and then
i we would talk i need someone because
there was something i wanted to talk
about before and i can't i just can't
remember
oh yes did i ever tell you about i've
told you about that dead dog at the
house party
did i ever tell you that one unclear at
this moment the house party dead dog
thing with my cannon okay so this is
i think you did tell me this and this is
did we say this on the podcast no but is
this something that was it's crazy a
crazy story i know the story i know this
story crazy
story
we have never talked about this on the
podcast because when you told me this i
think we were in motion and i almost
ejected my own body out of the car i
swear to god what you're about to say is
one of the most crazy stories i've ever
heard in my life house party with mike
cannon i'm gonna turn the air back on
keep talking yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so
there's a house party with mike cannon
so
they
have this party okay they have this
party you know 16 17 year old kids
the parents are away the parents are
away they're not in the house they're
supposed to be gone for three days
whatever it is so like many kids have a
house party
so like kids kids just start having a
house party they're teenagers whatever
they're drinking they're smoking weed
okay so as many kids would do this the
the kid
puts beer in the dog's bowl
and the dog starts drinking beer and
they're laughing because the dog's
getting drunk
then they start smoking weed and they
start they start hot boxing the dog with
wheat so they're getting the they're
getting the dog drunk and high
yeah okay they do this for have you
heard this story
well there's only one there's only one
time that you can hear for the first
time
okay i'm telling you okay so they do so
they're hot boxing this dog
and
they are giving it beer and they're
having a great time going off they're
having a great time the dog falls asleep
and they're like oh the dog's drunk
passed out it got high got drunk
whatever next morning comes around the
dog's dead
the dog is dead unfortunately the dog is
dead
everybody has ding dong the dog is dead
ding dong the dog is dead everybody has
left the party the kid wakes up drunk
hung over the dog's dead has no idea
what to do with that as he's realizing
this panic setting in his parents come
home early
from where they were going
he now
realizes i've thrown a house party
i've killed the family dog
my dad is walking into the house and my
mom are walking into the house
so what he does is he waits for them to
come and he takes the dead dog's body
out the back door
rests it up against a tree runs up back
into the house and says dad give me your
car keys give me your car keys i forgot
i have to go get milk or something
takes the car and backs it up
into the dog into the dead dog takes the
dead dog that he had previously placed
next to a tree he placed it next to the
tree runs up gets the keys
backs it up twice
into the dog
uh into the dog
long past dogs
for 12 hours yeah runs back in it says
oh my god
slits and marijuana
runs in says oh my god dad i just killed
the dog he goes
you're immediately going to military
school i watched you carry the dog
put it up against the tree and back up
into it twice
get out of my house you're going to
military school that's the last straw
and then he went to military school for
two years that's a true story that is in
the father is watching him re-kill the
dog twice and then lie about it and then
lie back he watched him carry the
lifeless body of the dog place it back
it up into it and this gentleman now
at the time being yet to that
subsequently his penance was to defend
our country yes he was like you're going
to defend the united states now that's
what you're going to do you're going to
fight iraq
it's it's it's it's it's life no liberty
and no pursuit of happiness it's just
the life yeah and then recently you know
of course upsetting my my family dog
died natural causes you know uh uh well
had to be put down i should say i had to
be put down and i'm in there i mean my
mother's very upset it's it's horrible
you know whatever um uh you know
comforting it's you know bad for me
whatever 15 years i'm the dog love the
dog shout out larry um
he's definitely the gay part of having
right now he's definitely gay dog loved
him god bless him he
you know he's still alive and they are
they i got something so he's alive you
know he's you know he's on his way out
and they put in the needle and they said
this is going to be painless they're
going to inject the the thing to kill
him whatever that is and it's going to
be painless he'll be dead and he'll
he'll just pass he'll just pass quietly
in the next 10 seconds
so they inject they quietly and 10
seconds to me are red flags yes so they
inject so they inject this substance
into him
and we're waiting and my mom's crying
and breathing heavy and that everyone's
rubbing her back and larry's still just
looking at us blinking
and we're saying
it's going to happen any second
so i say it's like cape canaveral so my
mom is just going and then and then and
then the doctor says i swear after about
sensitive doctors sometimes it can be
20.
i swear
the doctor's like don't yeah
so the doctor says sometimes it could be
20 seconds
and
he's going to pass it's just double this
it's just gonna be like it's just gonna
be like he's going into a dream uh to a
light sleep
larry's just
literally looking
dead
yeah yeah listening to us
so
now we're coming pictures of larry and
annabelle i want to see the comics
that's what it is if you're an animator
out there please make sure so now it's
upwards of 45 seconds
and larry's still just looking at us so
then my mother says
what is going on what's going on so then
the the vet says just give it a just
give it another moment she goes she goes
i'll be right back
she comes back in maybe 20 seconds later
she goes i apologize
she said my assistant is new here the
dog next door was dehydrated we gave
larry electrolytes
the vet says
the vet says over the next few minutes
you may see a little surge of energy
so
please
i swear to god
[Music]
she goes larry's like i'm gonna
because you know just put in his pawn
they injected
with the wrong thing and then she goes
so you may over the next few minutes see
he may all have had a center burst
energy she says she goes pay it no mind
because last hour is here
and then
he gets a burst
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so i'm like rubbing the back
whatever and then finally they come in
with the right stuff and then the the
that says to my most crumbling she goes
i promise you mrs i promise you i
promise you this substance will kill him
instantly
and i was like
my mom is like
head
i promise you once he's done being
replenished we will knock him back down
to size once he's done doing a couple of
laps around you know acting like a puppy
it's all fake we will kill the thing
that you've loved the motion this is
important now
we injected him with something to make
him useful like when you first met him
yeah it's smoking mirrors yeah just know
that electrolytes have a shelf life of
56 seconds yeah he's going to die he's
going to die hard the way you want the
way you want him
so finally that you know kills him
horrible you know horrible man i was
like i can't believe i went through that
ordeal i'm like i know whatever they
cremate him
my mom's waiting for the urn for the
cremation they said they would mail it
out
overnight it it will be there within 48
hours
we accidentally three days go by
three days four days five days no idea
where it is they mailed the urn to the
wrong address
wow so they mailed it to the wrong
address
oh my god
and finally we got it this was the
dalmatian this was no no this was the
dachshund
oh my god dude yeah yeah so that's i
don't mean to laugh but that's the
funniest thing i've ever heard in my
life i mean that's just i mean you're
trying to kill a dog you give him
electrolytes yeah he gave him
electrolytes because the dog next door
was dehydrated so imagine they would
have brought
and they killed the other dog right
she goes my assistant's new here you
know it's a learning curve
wow i should say yeah he's just silent
just blinking at him he keeps looking at
us he doesn't
she's like any sec i remember she said
sometimes it's 20.
[Laughter]
because you're trying to be peaceful and
somber thoughts and prayers don't
suppress so that she's like holy she's
like look at
annie
should be any second now
just he's gonna drift off
from where she came
visit his parents
i've never really seen it gone this long
but
just believe me he will pass
and three
two
[Music]
may have given the dog luckily
[Laughter]
yeah it was like literally i mean he
just kept blinking and looking up at us
my first dog i ever had uh house called
to put it down
and uh
i was so young and i didn't have enough
i wasn't the one in charge right and i
remember being really sad they put it
down in the yard that i lived in my
grandpa's house i lived downstairs they
put down the yard
and i was there and i was like talking
to her and i you know it happened and i
it was my first one that i ever lost
like that i was super sad and i was just
like you know what happens now i didn't
want to let it go right and
i swear to christ dude the doctor she
had one female assistant with him and it
was the doctor they pulled up in his own
car it was like camry
they came in the back in the yard they
put the dog down
10 seconds after the dog went down he
reached into a bag pulled out
hefty bit a black hefty bag went
and ripped it open threw the dog in the
bag picked the garbage a black garbage
makeup with the dead weight of the dog
in it walking down the side of my
grandfather's house down the steps onto
the block i was walking with them
because i was like
can i say something this doesn't feel
right he popped open his trunk threw the
dog in the trunk in the black orange
break closed it they were like all right
you know we'll send you the bill you
know we'll send you what you need and
they got in the car and they just drove
away and i was like
i cannot believe that this guy just
that's what it is there was no bedside
manner there was no protocol there was
no like there was no like tact no it was
just like this what we're gonna do
i know we've mentioned him three times
on the on the podcast oh my canon should
follow the great mike cannon at my
account on instagram he's had multiple
cats that have died in his house and he
buries them in his backyard by himself
i will tell you we had three dogs when i
looked at my grandparents one was a
chihuahua and when that dog died they
didn't tell me for weeks they said it
was in the hospital getting better
because they didn't want to break the
news to me i later found out my
grandfather buried it in the yard right
in the yard yeah
on that no yeah by the way it's illegal
it's legal to bury an animal on private
property illegally burying animal on
public property including parks so don't
get in good luck with that yeah i mean
sure i mean i i got news for you right
now if one day i get a dog and i have
property that dog is going in my in my
yard i'm gonna kill you okay come
yeah all right well listen you know i
know i i mean there's definitely like
every other episode there's definitely a
couple of things we didn't get back to
right
i wanted to [ __ ] on staten island real
estate like you can't imagine but i but
just because i want to live on staten
island and the people that i am trying
to buy the house from will not give me
the house even though i'm giving a full
price offer and and and and as much
money down as i can possibly spend well
let's let's do it next episode next step
is your venting episode
we've been trying to get it done for a
few episodes already so just let it go
let it fly from the beginning yeah uh
but the important thing is annabelle the
recently deceased rabbit i think is in
is the is the mascot now yes possible
possible visitations from stray yes
in the comic strip you might see stray
the blind cat yeah and you might see you
might see uh uh uh uh who's the clorox
dog
clorox dog or you might see
larry
larry i mean these are we're building a
universe of characters for this comic
strip but but but but let it be known
annabelle the recently deceased rabbit
is who i i want to breathe new life into
and i'm and i and i agree with that so
there you go this was hey babe hey babe
hey babe
hey babe
hey babe
hey babe